captain jack sparrow may be the
protagonist of the pirates of the
caribbean movies but he's definitely no
hero cannibal capers dastardly double
crossings and the creepiest seduction in
the franchise these are the most
terrible things jack sparrow has ever
done
the daughter of the fearsome pirate
blackbeard angelica forsook her father's
life of piracy clung to her catholic
faith and decided to become a nun
instead before taking her vows however
angelica is seduced by a young jack
sparrow who whisks her away from the
nunnery and leads her into a life of
crime after their time together
frustrated by a string of betrayals
angelica is left heartbroken by jack but
she has no way back to her old life
either because of this she eventually
joins her father's quest to find the
fountain of youth which jack also
manages to ruin by contributing to the
death of blackbeard himself at the
film's end rather than apologizing for
his mistakes or even just taking her
back to civilization jack strands
angelica on a deserted island ruining
her life yet again
jack sparrow and betrayals go together
like ships and the sea no matter who you
are your relation to him or how aligned
you think your goals might be jack will
always find a way to twist the scenario
to his own benefit at your expense
in curse of the black pearl jack
convinces commodore james norrington to
engage with captain barbosa and his men
on the isla de muerta in a surprise
attack only to immediately reveal said
plan to barbosa in exchange for his own
life
roberts your uncle fanny's your aunt
there you are with two ships
this results in the slaughter of many of
norrington's men as barbossa's skeleton
army takes them out one by one nearly
overtaking their ship
much of the blood spilled during this
attack is directly the result of jack's
meddling but it is later revealed to be
part of his master plan soon after jack
and will turner lift the skeletal curse
and barbosa's army are returned to their
normal human forms just in time for the
british to overtake the pirates sparing
the rest of their lives
this little stunt still cost the lives
of countless men however and it's fair
to say that jack really doesn't seem all
that cut up about it
if dead man's chest taught us anything
about jack it's that he's definitely not
an innocent man
both earthly authorities and
supernatural beings have pursued him
across the caribbean
after meeting back up with will turner
jack sends the boy off to the flying
dutchman to join davy jones's crew in an
effort to save his own skin
he has no problem telling jones that
will soul should count towards his own
mystical debt
of course nothing is quite that simple
in the pirates universe
jones demands more souls than just will
but he's happy to take the young pirate
nonetheless so jack happily leaves will
to his fate heads to tortuga and tries
to collect 99 more souls innocent people
who will be condemned to servitude so
that jack can escape a promise he once
made it's not exactly his finest hour
earlier in dead man's chest will find
jack and his crew run aground on a
tribal island somewhere in the caribbean
on this island jack was somehow able to
become the tribe's leader but what he
doesn't know is that the members of the
tribe have planned to eat him he
eventually escapes although he seems to
be fully aware that the tribe has been
saving will and his crew for the fleshly
feast
when will meets up with jack rather than
telling will to free the crew and help
them get out of there he begs will to
save him alone with no consideration for
the crew at all now sure jack was as
much a prisoner of the cannibal tribe as
anyone but when jack and the crew first
arrived on the island he probably could
have convinced the locals not to lock up
his friends
knowing jack's inherent selfishness it's
clear he was only thinking of himself
and if will hadn't arrived there's no
telling what would have happened to the
crew
after being resurrected in at world's
end jack quickly makes a deal with lord
cutler beckett the governor of the east
india trading company beckett wants
information about the brethren court the
pirate lords and the nine pieces of
eight jack does him one better he tells
beckett that he'll lead him to shipwreck
cove the meeting place of the pirate
lords then at shipwreck cove jack plans
to convince the pirates to go to war so
that they can be annihilated by beckett
and his vast armada why would jack do
this well his original end game was to
flee ship wreck cove and sail the seas
forever as the last of his kind
quite like the sound of that
captain jack sparrow
the last pirate
and so jack makes his deal with beckett
and leads him to the meeting place of
the pirates then true to his word he
convinces them to sail out and fight
while jack sparrow clearly works in
mysterious ways and beckett is
eventually defeated it's easy to imagine
that jack's plan to betray his fellow
swashbucklers was genuine even just for
a little while
a recurring thread throughout the
original pirates of the caribbean
trilogy is that jack has a bit of a
crush on elizabeth swann unfortunately
for jack elizabeth is strong confident
and fearless meaning she's really not
the type of girl who would be interested
in him knowing full well how will feels
about her however jack constantly
attempts to take advantage of and seduce
elizabeth including by getting her drunk
on a beach naturally elizabeth is a bit
too smart for jack and she manages to
use her feminine prowess against him at
the end of dead man's chest by the time
jack sees elizabeth again he doesn't
seem to trust her but eventually comes
around and supports her as the new
pirate king when the chips are down
still his constant pursuit of elizabeth
earlier in the series provides an
unsettling glimpse into jack's
womanizing ways
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]